foreign
hi Cindy how are you
hi Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um we have my husband and I have 460
000 in Money Market type account and
then we have 135 000 in cash
and we're to the point of saying what do
we do with this we're not making any
profit on most of that money and um we
took the 460 out of equities and
securities because we were losing a lot
of money in that and uh that money had
come from a home that we sold and
because we got an interest rate of 2.5
on a new home uh we went with the 2.5
and put the 460 into Securities
inequities and uh didn't want to lose it
beyond what we put in there so we put it
in the money market
what do you own your home
366k okay
um
from 30 years of coaching people how to
become wealthy and from doing a study of
10 000 millionaires
these are the two sources for my data
that tells me the shortest distance
between where you are and wealth is two
things as a um
consistently funded
401K Roth IRA in good growth stock
mutual funds over a long period of time
there becomes some money and a paid for
house our last debt-free screen was a
six hundred thousand dollar
uh paid for house and eight hundred
thousand dollars in their 401k or
reverse I forget which but it was 1.4
million dollar net worth
and it was just a few moments ago while
you were on hold you heard it
yes okay so that is the typical path
that we see that is the most often used
by people who become millionaires now
where does that take us in your
situation it says I would pay off my
house today
because here's what you ended up doing
it wasn't the start of your plan
but the net result of your plan is you
borrowed money at 2.35 percent and
invested it at a half a percent
right yes sir we were I know that wasn't
where you that wasn't what you set out
to do but that's where you ended up
isn't it
it is I paid off my house today today
my close of business today
write a check
okay
okay and now you don't have any house
payment anymore how does that feel
awesome because I want to retire yeah
and now you got two hundred thousand
dollars in cash that we got to do
something better than a stupid money
market account with you need an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses for your short-term emergencies
and um I mean you know let's call that
50 Grand at your house for the fun of it
you've still got 150 000 that you need
to do something with other than a stupid
but savings account now if you put it
into some kind of a mix with a stock
broker and you were losing money I get
that if you put it into good mutual
funds on the overall economy slowdown
like it is right now and the value went
down
then you didn't have somebody good in
your corner to coach you and say hey the
only person gets hurt on a roller
coaster is those that jump off in the
middle of the ride which is exactly what
you did
now were you invested in single stocks
no you're a mutual funds
versified in mutual funds
some of them were mutual funds okay well
what I would do is sit down with a good
investment broker and here's what you're
looking for this time
um and uh you're looking for someone
with a heart of a teacher that teaches
you the history of the mutual fund that
you're putting the money into
okay I'll give you an example I own one
that's over 80 years old in the 80 years
it's been open fewer than 15 of the
those 80 years has have been a down year
so if we happen to have it down year and
I know that
I know that not my broker knows that but
I know that then I'm not freaking out
it's kind of like the house that you own
in Baton Rouge if it went down in value
this year you wouldn't freak out because
generally speaking homes in the
neighborhood you live in for the past 40
years have gone up in value agreed
agreed so you wouldn't freak out on one
down year and bail out that's just like
that mutual fund I'm describing I'm not
going to freak out in one down year and
bail out but that's all knowledge on
your part rather than depending on
someone else to tell you what to do and
then you get scared because you watch
the news
and you never take Financial advice from
the news
if the commercial breaks where you're
watching TV or walk-in bathtubs gold
commercials and reverse mortgages and
Snuggies that tells you you don't want
to take Financial advice there
that's just a bad plan and so
here's me looking at you fox but anyway
yeah so there you go but the uh Fox
Business right but I love them they're
wonderful but the commercials are
comical Saturday Night Live so hard like
I can't hold it in you're not seeing
walking bathtubs are a bad idea just the
investment advice I'm just saying if
this is where you get your Investments
inside the commercial breaks or walk-in
bathtubs and Snuggies then you know
you're not getting good this is this is
a bad place
oh that was perfect I'm sorry that just
got me that was like the church giggle I
couldn't hold it we've all sat and
watched them at the commercials I know
exactly I know exactly what you're
talking about yeah and and we're on
there giving Financial advice so what do
we know but anyway the uh uh but you
know you really need to sit with a good
broker who has the heart of a teacher go
to ramseysolutions.com click on
smartvestor sit down with them interview
them and what you're looking for here is
is a type of wisdom not intellect
there's a difference
there's a lot of very very intellectual
ignoramuses out there
and that's not in the world in in
general that's not what you're looking
for you're looking for common sense
wisdom that says I bought a mutual fund
that for 80 years has only had less than
15 down years so we're having it down
here I don't need to panic
and that you learn that you internalize
that you emotionally swallow that and
then it becomes part of your plan and so
in that situation then you invest in
good mutual funds in your 401ks and your
Roth IRAs and those kinds of things and
you get your house paid for and that's
what I'm going to do with your 150
unless you've got other debts and then
we'll clean that up too
so I want you to debt free a hundred
percent and investing in good growth
stock mutual funds that is the shortest
that have long track records that are
comfortable to you and that you
understand what's going on you didn't do
it because I should do it or because
some goob at a financial office said do
it it's because you learned and your
knowledge allows you to sleep at night
you know Ken that's the difference
between tossing and turning at night
when the stock market's down yeah is
whether you made the decision based on
the knowledge you had or knowledge
someone else had yeah well it's true I
mean you know for years I mean before I
even started working with you this idea
that roller coaster analogy that you've
given it's really true and you look at
the data if you look over the last 30
years you just got to stay calm and ride
this thing out I just don't freak out
when I see the stock market dip you know
I say hey we keep investing that's an
opportunity it's going to come back and
and you're right knowledge uh is what
gives us tremendous confidence and
confidence the piece yeah and once you
really understand that folks about the
stock market then when it goes down you
kind of go like it's on sale yeah we're
getting bargained it's a bargain time
Yep this is a ton to buy well we don't
really do that either because I'm not
going to tell you to time the market I'm
just going to tell you steady invest
steady invest that's all I have done I
have been tempted at times when the
market is down to time it yeah I really
really wish in 2008 when the stock
market was crashing in the world's
coming to an end and it went from 13 000
to 6500 I really wish I had put an extra
million dollars in
yeah
because I mean the Dow's sitting at what
6X of that that million wow today would
be worth 6 million wow because the Dow's
you know thirty thousand over thirty
thousand right so um yeah there you go I
mean that's 5x 5x yeah it'll be worth
five million dollars now ultimately I
did have money in there and it's worth
5x but if you could have timed the
market and bought at the pot lowest
possible time we've seen in decades then
that would have been the time to do it
but who knew when the bottom was if I
bought a 6500 it would have gone to six
thousand
[Laughter]
that I'd have been pissed I missed the
bottom not that I was going to lose
money but because I missed the bottom so
don't try the time the market people
trying to try on the market don't win
they really don't and jumping in and out
based on what you hear on the news based
on whether or not Russia invades Ukraine
is really a bad idea
you gotta have a long-term scope on this
stuff and ride it out and that includes
having your house paid off Cindy so
thank you for calling we appreciate you
being in our audience this is the Ramsay
show